the building isn't complete but Sudanese
refugees have found temporary shelter
here the conditions are harsh and they
lack the very Basics to survive now they
also live in fear since president
kaisaya's February statement that
accused sub-Saharan Africans of taking
part in a plot to change tunisia's
demographics
following the decision that has been
issued in recent days we stopped working
and we no longer know where to go
most of these refugees have lost their
jobs and some of them said that they
were subjected to attacks they came to
the headquarters of the UN Refugee
agency to ask for protection and
resettlement
others gathered in front of the Ivory
Coast Embassy in the capital Tunis
attempting to get return tickets to
their countries
they are racist people who do not want
to see Africans here and for them it
does not matter if you are a student
with residency documents or not they do
not deal with us as a human beings but
see us as masters from a forest
president Zaya denied accusations of
racism and announced measures to protect
African refugees
they are in another world what happened
was a misunderstanding that I could
describe as Not Innocent the important
thing is to respect the Tunisian law
these are our brothers I reiterate they
are our brothers so what are they
talking about with this campaign
[Applause]
[Music]
many tunisians Express solidarity with
refugees rejecting offensive statements
or actions against them
they were angry that their government is
being accused of racism but also feel
ashamed of the violence and hope the
crises will not spoil Tunisia or
undermine its values